én azt szoktam mondani a férfiaknak hogy
méltóvá kell válni ott lenni annak a
nőnek az oldalán aki aki téged
választott és úgy tudunk méltóvá válni
vagy úgy tudnak vagy úgy tudtok
férfiként méltóvá válni hogy kihúzzátok
magatokat felismeritek az értékeiteket
és ezeket
megmutatjátok nem csak a nő miatt hanem
önmagatok miatt is mert akkor
megteremtitek azt a felületet ahova
kapcsolódni tudnak mások is és megint
csak én abszolút meggyőződésem hogy a
világ akkor tud jobb len hogyha mi
egyenként kicsiként a saját világainkat
egy picit jobbá tesszük ez viszont csak
akkor lehetséges ha látszunk ha nem
látszom ha elbújok ha elmenekülök a
felelősség elől akkor úgy könnyű nem az
én hibám nem én tehetek róla nem tudom
befolyásolni